Kryłowska diagonalizacja kwantowa, w skrócie KQD, polega na rozwiązaniu zagadnienia wartości własnych macierzy
poprzez rzutowanie macierzy na podprzestrzeń przygotowaną na komputerze kwantowym, zgodnie z metodą Kryłowa —
potężnym podejściem zaczerpniętym z klasycznej algebry liniowej. W tym filmie zbadamy, do czego metoda Kryłowa jest użyteczna
oraz jak i kiedy stosować ją na komputerach kwantowych.
Czym więc jest metoda Kryłowa? Załóżmy, że mamy macierz H związaną z jakimś zagadnieniem naukowym lub biznesowym, o n wierszach i n
kolumnach. Interesuje nas najniższa wartość własna e 0 oraz odpowiadający jej wektor własny psi 0. Zdefiniujmy
wektor początkowy v, który może być motywowany strukturą H lub może być całkowicie losowy. Podprzestrzeń Kryłowa
rzędu r, którą zapisujemy jako K r, jest generowana przez działanie H na ten
wektor początkowy r minus jeden razy, dodając wynik każdego kolejnego działania H
do zbioru wektorów rozpinających — czyli K r jest przestrzenią rozpinaną przez wektory v,
Hv, H kwadrat i tak dalej. Wektory te na ogół nie będą ortogonalne.
Klasycznie często przeprowadzamy proces ortogonalizacji bardzo podobny do procedury Grama-Schmidta. Zaczynamy
od normalizacji wektora początkowego V i wynik nazywamy V 0. Następnie dla kolejnego wektora HV odejmujemy jego
rzut na V 0, aby oba wektory były ortogonalne. Potem normalizujemy wynik. Kontynuujemy w ten sposób,
działając ponownie H i sprawiając, że wynik jest ortogonalny do wszystkich wcześniej dodanych wektorów, dopóki nie uzyskamy R
ortonormowanych wektorów potrzebnych do rozpięcia R-wymiarowej podprzestrzeni Kryłowa.
Gdy mamy już tę podprzestrzeń, rzutujemy na nią naszą macierz i diagonalizujemy mniejszą macierz rzutowaną. Istnieją
subtelności i rozszerzenia, ale to jest metoda Kryłowa w jej najprostszej postaci.
Żeby lepiej zrozumieć, jak to działa, przyjrzyjmy się trywialnemu przykładowi. Jeśli H to ta macierz, a V jest tym
wektorem, to zaczęlibyśmy od normalizacji V. Aby wygenerować drugi wektor podprzestrzeni Kryłowa, działamy
raz H na nasz wektor początkowy, a następnie ortogonalizujemy wynik względem V 0.
Prosta algebra daje nam to dla V1.
Dla tak małych macierzy jest to bezużyteczne i zazwyczaj nie zatrzymywalibyśmy się przy wymiarze Kryłowa równym dwa. Ale gdybyśmy
mieli rzutować H na nową podprzestrzeń Kryłowa K2, zrobilibyśmy to używając macierzy V,
która ma wektor Kryłowa w każdej kolumnie, oraz jej sprzężenia transponowanego z wektorami Kryłowa w wierszach. Uzyskalibyśmy wtedy
tę macierz.
Ta macierz ma technicznie niższy wymiar niż nasza oryginalna. Oczywiście to zmniejszenie nie jest użyteczne w tej
skali. Metoda ta jest przeznaczona do redukcji macierzy z wieloma tysiącami lub nawet milionami wierszy i kolumn
do zaledwie kilku. Dlaczego więc metody Kryłowa są użyteczne? Okazuje się, że ten prosty przepis
działania operatorem jest często najefektywniejszym sposobem zbliżania się do stanu o najniższej wartości własnej, czyli stanu podstawowego macierzy
operator. Uczyńmy to nieco bardziej precyzyjnym, choć pełny dowód zostawimy tekstowi towarzyszącemu. Chcemy
rozwiązać problem postaci: H działające na wektor x daje nam pewną stałą razy wektor x. Zacznijmy od
zgadnięcia naszego wektora własnego x0. To tylko przybliżone rozwiązanie. Ma błąd, który nazywamy e 0. Teraz chcemy
zaktualizować to zgadnięcie, co nazwiemy x1, mając nadzieję, że poprawi nasze przybliżenie. Możemy to wyrazić jako
oryginalne x0 plus pewna korekta p 0, którą jeszcze trzeba wyznaczyć. Możemy
powtarzać ten proces iteracyjnie, dodając coraz więcej wektorów korekcyjnych pi.
Oczywiście chcemy, żeby nasz błąd malał, ale nie tylko stan nas interesuje. Interesuje nas też
działanie H na ten stan. Tak więc wielkością, którą naprawdę chcemy minimalizować, jest norma H tego błędu, czyli norma
działania H na ten błąd.
Widzimy teraz, że jest to wyrażenie zawierające p 0, i możemy się zastanowić, jaki wybór p minimalizuje
tę normę H błędu najefektywniej. Z jakiej przestrzeni powinniśmy wybierać korekcję? W pewnych
warunkach, takich jak gdy H jest symetryczne i dodatnio określone, wybieranie pierwszych r korekt z wnętrza K r okazuje się
optymalne. Mówiąc prościej, potrzebujemy pewnego sposobu przygotowania dobrej podprzestrzeni, na którą możemy
rzutować nasz Hamiltonian. W wielu przypadkach podprzestrzeń Kryłowa jest przestrzenią rozpinaną przez wektory najefektywniejszych
korekt do naszego początkowego zgadnięcia.
Pełny dowód znajdziesz w tekście towarzyszącym temu filmowi.
Wszystko, co do tej pory opisaliśmy, można zrobić klasycznie. Jak i kiedy więc użylibyśmy komputera kwantowego?
Dla bardzo dużych macierzy metoda Kryłowa może wymagać długich czasów obliczeń i dużych ilości pamięci. Czas
wymagany do wykonania działania macierzy H na V skaluje się jak N kwadrat w najgorszym przypadku.
I wykonuje się to dla każdego wektora, który chcemy mieć w naszej podprzestrzeni. Wymiar podprzestrzeni R zazwyczaj nie stanowi istotnej
części N i często skaluje się jak logarytm z N. Tak więc generowanie wszystkich wektorów skaluje się
jak rząd N^2 log N.
Choć są inne kroki, jak ortogonalizacja, to to jest dominujące skalowanie, o którym warto pamiętać.
Obliczenia kwantowe pozwalają nam zmienić to, jakie właściwości problemu wyznaczają skalowanie czasu i zasobów
wymaganych do obliczeń. Zamiast zależności od rozmiaru macierzy n, zobaczymy rzeczy takie jak liczba strzałów i
liczba niekomutujących składników Pauliego tworzących Hamiltonian.
Przyjrzyjmy się, jak to działa.
Przypomnij sobie, że operator ewolucji czasowej stanu kwantowego to eksponenta z iH przez h bar. I
bardzo powszechne jest, szczególnie w obliczeniach kwantowych, pomijanie h bar w notacji.
Jednym ze sposobów zrozumienia, a nawet realizacji takiej funkcji eksponencjalnej operatora, jest spojrzenie na jej
rozwinięcie w szereg Fouriera. Zauważ, że ta operacja działająca na pewien wektor początkowy V daje sumę składników
z rosnącymi potęgami H działającego na stan początkowy. Wygląda na to, że możemy po prostu tworzyć naszą podprzestrzeń Kryłowa poprzez ewolucję czasową
naszego początkowego stanu zgadnięcia. I to prawie prawda. Zastrzeżenie dotyczy
realizacji ewolucji czasowej na prawdziwym komputerze kwantowym. Wiele składników Hamiltonianu nie będzie komutować ze sobą
nawzajem. Tak więc, choć niektóre proste operatory eksponencjalne, jak e do minus i z, odpowiadają prostym
circuit, ogólne hamiltoniany takie nie są, a ponieważ zawierają niekomutujące składniki,
nie możemy po prostu rozkładać eksponenty na iloczyn prostych, tak jak możemy to robić z liczbami. Tak więc
nie jest to trywialne, ale jest to dobrze zbadany proces w obliczeniach kwantowych. Ewolucję czasową
na komputerach kwantowych przeprowadzamy używając procesu zwanego trotteryzacją, która sama w sobie jest bogatym tematem. Ale na bardzo wysokim poziomie,
dzieląc ewolucję czasową na małe kroki, powiedzmy M kroków, ograniczamy efekty niekomutowania
składników. Nazwijmy podprzestrzeń Kryłowa rzędu r, którą wygenerowaliśmy w kontekście klasycznym używając potęg H
bezpośrednio, potęgową podprzestrzenią Kryłowa KPR.
Teraz generujemy podobną przestrzeń używając unitarnego operatora ewolucji czasowej U danego przez eksponentę z iHt.
Będziemy to nazywać unitarną podprzestrzenią Kryłowa KUR.
Potęgowa podprzestrzeń Kryłowa KPR, której używamy klasycznie, nie może być wygenerowana bezpośrednio na komputerze kwantowym, ponieważ H
nie jest operatorem unitarnym. Można pokazać, że używanie unitarnej podprzestrzeni Kryłowa daje podobne gwarancje zbieżności
jak potęgowa podprzestrzeń Kryłowa.
Konkretnie, błąd stanu podstawowego zbiega się efektywnie, dopóki początkowy stan V ma nakładanie ze
stanem prawdziwym, które nie zanika wykładniczo, i dopóki istnieje wystarczający odstęp między wartościami
własnymi. Tutaj potęgi U stają się różnymi krokami czasowymi. K-ta potęga U to przesunięcie
o czas k * dt do przodu.
Możemy oznaczać element podprzestrzeni, który ewoluował czasowo przez łączny czas kdt, jako s sub k. Możemy rzutować nasz
Hamiltonian H na unitarną podprzestrzeń Kryłowa KUR. Innymi słowy,
obliczamy każdy element macierzowy H w bazie KUR. Będziemy tę
macierz rzutowaną nazywać H tilda. Elementy macierzowe H tilda są dane przez te wartości oczekiwane, które można
szacować używając komputera kwantowego.
Pamiętaj, że H można zapisać jako sumę operatorów Pauliego na różnych qubit, a nie wszystkie operatory Pauliego
można mierzyć jednocześnie. Możemy sortować składniki Pauliego w grupy komutujących składników i mierzyć wszystkie
naraz. Ale może nam być potrzebnych wiele takich grup, żeby pokryć wszystkie składniki. Tak więc liczba różnych grup komutujących, na które
składniki można podzielić, NGCP, staje się ważna. Jeśli używamy unitarnej podprzestrzeni Kryłowa wymiaru r, wynikowa
macierz będzie miała wymiary r * r. Jeśli r jest dużo mniejsze od n, to poczyniliśmy
użyteczny postęp, a zazwyczaj r jest dużo mniejsze od 100, co oznacza, że możemy łatwo diagonalizować tę macierz na klasycznym
komputerze. Pamiętaj jednak, że s n i s m na ogół nie będą ortogonalne. Czasami
jest możliwe diagonalizowanie macierzy w nieortogonalnej bazie. Ale istnieją numeryczne i fizyczne powody,
dla których warto najpierw przejść do ortogonalnej bazy. Dlatego rozwiązujemy uogólniony problem wartości własnych używając macierzy Grama S.
Element mn macierzy Grama jest dany przez iloczyn wewnętrzny s m na s n.
Zarówno elementy H tilda, jak i S są obliczane używając testu Hadamarda.
Uogólniony problem wartości własnych przyjmuje wtedy tę postać.
Jak wspomniano powyżej, wymiar unitarnej podprzestrzeni Kryłowa R jest wykładniczo mniejszy od naszego początkowego
wymiaru macierzy N. Tak więc ten problem wartości własnych jest prosty do rozwiązania klasycznie.
Podsumowując, zaczynamy od stanu referencyjnego, a następnie ewoluujemy go przez różne okresy czasu, aby wygenerować unitarną
podprzestrzeń Kryłowa. Rzutujemy nasz Hamiltonian na tę podprzestrzeń i szacujemy też nakładania wektorów
podprzestrzeni. Na koniec rozwiązujemy niskowymiarowy uogólniony problem wartości własnych klasycznie. Porównajmy, co
wyznacza koszty obliczeniowe stosowania techniki Kryłowa klasycznie i kwantowo. Zarysowaliśmy to
już dla wersji klasycznej i nie ma doskonałych analogii między podejściami klasycznym i kwantowym dla wszystkich kroków. Ale ta tabela zbiera pewne
skalowania różnych kroków do rozważenia. Pamiętaj, że Hamiltoniany na ogół mają składniki, które nie mogą być mierzone jednocześnie, ponieważ
nie komutują. Sortujemy składniki Hamiltonianu w grupy komutujących operatorów Pauliego, które można mierzyć jednocześnie, i może nam być potrzebnych wiele
takich grup, żeby uwzględnić wszystkie niekomutujące składniki. Zbudowanie H tilda na komputerze kwantowym wymaga
oddzielnych pomiarów dla każdej grupy komutujących łańcuchów Pauliego w Hamiltonianie. A każdy z nich wymaga wielu strzałów. Musimy to robić dla R
kwadrat różnych elementów macierzowych odpowiadających R kwadrat kombinacji różnych czynników ewolucji czasowej. Istnieją
czasem sposoby na zmniejszenie tego. Ale w tym przybliżonym podejściu, czas wymagany do tego skaluje się mniej więcej jak
liczba strzałów razy liczba grup komutujących składników Pauliego razy r^2.
Elementy S muszą być szacowane, co skaluje się jak liczba strzałów
razy r do sześcianu. Widzimy, że kwantowa diagonalizacja Kryłowa może być użyteczna w przypadkach, gdy liczba komutujących grup Pauliego
w Hamiltonianie jest stosunkowo mała.
Ta zależność skalowania sugeruje pewne zastosowania, w których metoda Kryłowa może być użyteczna, i inne, gdzie prawdopodobnie
nie będzie. Niektóre Hamiltoniany mają wysoką złożoność przy mapowaniu na qubit, obejmując wiele niekomutujących łańcuchów Pauliego,
których nie można łatwo podzielić na kilka grup komutujących.
Często dotyczy to problemów chemii kwantowej. Na przykład, ta złożoność stwarza dwa główne wyzwania dla
bliskoterminowych komputerów kwantowych. Po pierwsze, szacowanie każdego elementu H tilda staje się kosztowne obliczeniowo z powodu
dużej liczby składników. Po drugie, wymagane circuit trotteryzacji stają się zbyt głębokie. Oba te punkty
będą mniej problematyczne, gdy komputery kwantowe osiągną tolerancję na błędy, ale muszą być brane pod uwagę w bliskim terminie. Nawet systemy z prostszymi mapowaniami
niż te w chemii kwantowej mogą napotkać te same przeszkody, jeśli Hamiltoniany mają zbyt wiele niekomutujących
składników. Metoda Kryłowa jest najbardziej użyteczna tam, gdzie Hamiltonian można podzielić na stosunkowo niewiele komutujących grup Pauliego
i gdzie H jest łatwy do zaimplementowania w circuit trotteryzacji. Oba te warunki są spełnione na przykład
dla wielu modeli sieciowych interesujących w fizyce. KQD jest szczególnie użyteczne, gdy bardzo mało wiadomo o
stanie podstawowym. Wynika to z jego wbudowanych gwarancji zbieżności i zastosowania w scenariuszach, gdzie
alternatywne metody są niewykonalne z powodu niewystarczającej wiedzy o stanie podstawowym.
Choć KQD jest potężnym narzędziem, czasochłonne aspekty protokołu — w szczególności szacowanie każdego
elementu rzutowanego Hamiltonianu i nakładania stanów Kryłowa — stanowią obszary do poprawy. Alternatywne
podejście polega na aproksymacji stanu Kryłowa używając circuit trotteryzacji, a następnie próbkowaniu
aproksymowanego stanu w celu uzyskania rzutu na bazę obliczeniową i rzutowania H na podprzestrzeń
rozpinaną przez te stany bazy obliczeniowej.
W przypadkach, gdy jest to możliwe, ta metodologia, znana jako oparta na próbkowaniu kwantowa diagonalizacja Kryłowa SKQD,
potencjalnie oferuje znaczące zmniejszenie czasu i wymagań zasobów w porównaniu z tradycyjnym KQD.
Integracja technik podprzestrzeni Kryłowa z metodami próbkowania w SKQD reprezentuje ekscytujący przełom w
algorytmach kwantowych.